I finally come to the realization that me and my husband
change up our entire lives
and pretty much who we are about every five years.
Sometimes these are small things,
sometimes they're big things.
Like, literally,
five years ago, we lived in a different part of town.
I was a gym rat. I only really wore athleisure wear.
I didn't have social media,
at least not like, public social media.
And we were dead set on being done having kids at two.
The cool thing, though,
is that no matter how much I change,
no matter how much my husband changes,
no matter how much her life changes,
we tend to do it together.
Like we are fully on for each other's journey.
And I'm starting to feel our chapter turn again,
and I just can't wait to see what we're gonna turn out
as for the next one.